today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza great block pizza it's
a place where they have pizza and you
knew that already
gray block get that hitter today's
episode is brought to you by the M in ml
case that's the minimal case the world's
thinnest phone case go to any countries
a year
Somalia United Republic of Congo Japan
and you will still only have one
thinnest case and that is the MN ml case
the minimal case it's just point zero
one inches thick it's basically like a
hard condom for your phone if your phone
wants to get into something naughty
sultry maybe go to a steak house maybe
go lean up against a piano or a dark
alley and listen to jazz music well
there's only one phone case to do it in
and that's the minimal case the MN ml
case there's a hundred percent
money-back guarantee if you're unhappy
for whatever reason they will refund the
purchase of this mentioned case no need
to send the case back at all keep the
case get your cash back you can get 20%
off by visiting M in ml CA se comm use
promo code Theo
that's promo code th EO for 20% off at M
in ml CAS e.com now if you're going on
the Rocky Mountains you're gonna throw
this thing into a wishing well you might
want to tougher case but if you want
something sleek and clean and something
I mean good god you can slide this thing
anywhere then you're gonna want the MN
ml case com promo code Theo today's
episode is a young man who I'll be
honest with the audit I don't know if ya
if you had Tourette's or not if I'm
being totally frank we were looking for
a Tourette's guy someone who had
Tourette's or has had Tourette's a lot
of our listeners know I beat Down
syndrome when I was young you know the
doctors said 95% chance that he has it
and then eventually said 40% chance and
other time I was like 11 years old
they're like 0% chance maybe 5% chance
so I understand people overcoming
afflictions and rare diseases but this
guy we look we wanted to have somebody
in who had Tourette's and Tourette's is
a French disease that made its way to
America and afflicts millions of people
maybe even hundreds of millions and and
we had a fascinating conversation he was
very kind to come in he's given TED
talks on the subject and and this is a
man who found a way to master you know
those uh you know those you know one of
the Lord's most dangerous and wild gifts
which is Tourette's ladies and gentlemen
our guest today is Ted talker author and
Tourette's defeater mr. mark Eliot
[Music]
I'm sitting here mark Ellie thanks for
joining us today brother thanks for
having me for you yeah I appreciate it
man
and I was like cuz you you know I was
looking at some of your videos listed
looking at your TED talk and I was like
wow this guy you know at first I was
like because it's about Tourette's
mostly about Tourette syndrome you know
it's about a lot of things yeah yeah
well okay so then well tell me what
Tourette's is man so if somebody doesn't
know Tourette's you know like what is it
okay so so when I grew up yeah let me
start there because I think it's a
little bit easier okay the way that that
I understood Tourette syndrome is that
it's a neurological genetic disorder
that's involuntary and has no cure yeah
it's somebody working freelance really
on their own you know it's somebody just
the Lord I feel like it's just remix in
somebody and they're just kind of shook
we know some people I mean it's sort of
I mean for it it's bizarre when you see
somebody you know ticking because it's
obviously if you know it it's not as
bizarre yeah but you know just from you
know if you're just walking or you're at
McDonald's or you're walking somewhere
and you just start seeing someone bark
like a dog yeah doing things
uncontrollably that it's we had a dude
named Jim wager and he would bust out
the n-word every now and then I know and
I don't use the n-word unless you do
know what I'm saying
but um he was this white guy and he
would just and so a lot of times people
would just take him over and like set
him in like the black area of like the
school yard you know and just run off
and like just wait for him to go off you
know and then uh and that was kind of
wild I mean you know like so you have I
mean I guess kids can be more cruel
about it but yeah I guess for most
people if they think about it like if I
think about it I don't know about most
people but it's like yeah it's a it's a
it's a disease or it's a syndrome or
it's a thing where you were like
involuntary it's almost like somebody is
like you're a puppet of of you know some
Dark Lord or something Dark Lord yes I
mean some people did I think some people
believe that you actually are possessed
by the devil kind of yeah it looks
it looks it's just intense when you're
watching it yeah but let me just explain
a little bit of how I actually
experienced it because it sort of
evolved over the years okay but we're
headed you still have it you have you
had it I don't have it anymore you beat
it I beat it hell yeah dude hell yeah
you beat it man
so and I don't say that I cured it I
mean it was right a journey okay um and
we can talk tomorrow yeah but basically
you know I even posted some videos about
this but basically the way that I
experience Tourette's is that there's a
very uncomfortable feeling on the inside
yes okay so I always read it tell people
you don't think of an itch right you
know stuff like you think of an itch
right now you're probably just get one
rush it's how it work I don't know how
that works with the mind yeah
it's craft that's called it's craft it's
crap yes so there's C exactly yeah so
yeah you can start if you think that you
get it you started thinking about it
okay so there's this uncomfortable
feeling in my body okay and when I was a
kid the only way I knew how to get rid
of that feeling was to or to say a word
or two you know hump my thrusts my my
hips whatever I was okay and as soon as
I tipped em hmm that it went away okay
and it felt amazing right you just feel
so much better because that discomfort
whatever that itches it was gone now of
course when I was a kid I didn't have
that type of understanding about it
though I just was there was so basically
there's an understanding of us so you're
just living it I'm just living it and I
wasn't like oh I have this this isn't
doing it always one big mesh kind of
ball of Tourette's you know yeah and the
the thing is when you use that analogy
though you have to be careful because
people could then you know say well why
do you just not scratch it just don't
don't scratch it
and that's a great question but it's
tough you know imagine having ten like
instead of just that one edge that you
might be feeling on your leg imagine now
having 10 15 20 itches yeah all in one
spot
yeah oh well then if somebody look to
you and says I have an itch right now
and I'm not scratching it that person is
we usually you know that person's with
satan or that person is like uh that's a
sociopath I can't imagine somebody
leaning over to me like a man I have the
biggest it I'm like you know my leg it
my are magicians so bad but guess what
I'm not gonna scratch it you're like
what a psychopath you know so yeah
wanting to scratch an itch that's
totally normal you can't not it's like
you would do it no matter what
yes and growing up I didn't I didn't
know of any other way it could be right
that was just the way it was right and
so my definition of Tourette's now has
sort of evolved over time but this is
kind of interesting for me and this is
just my opinion yeah that itch that I
described to me that's Tourette's
syndrome okay that feeling whatever that
is and then when you see somebody tick
or somebody would see me tick that was
actually me in a sense coping with my
Tourette's okay does that make sense yes
it makes sense so the itch is the
Tourette's the uncomfortability the you
know the but you know the baffling
uncomfortability the need to do
something to the incontrolable desire to
act yes um that is the itch that's the
Tourette's and then your reaction your
tick is a it's the release it's a way
that I can get rid of that that
uncomfortable feeling because as soon as
that feeling goes away you feel normal
you're normal yeah with Tourette
syndrome it's difficult because that
feeling comes right back okay
you know it starts to build up again you
know now how is there special ways like
I remember this one kid like the same
kid this boy Jim wager at school they
would put like you know if they laid him
on the no joke they'd lay him on the
ground sometime put like semen on his
back cement pieces and he would not get
it for a while and it would like what do
you mean cement pee calm him down just
like you know blocks not cinder blocks
but thick kind of chunks of cement you
know so anyway like I don't know if
there was the weight of it or something
it would kind of like you know it would
exacerbate the desire or the build up I
guess I'm interests
him you know I mean it was also kind of
old school you know not doctor you know
you do whatever you can I mean yeah but
I remember yeah at one point they were
stacking and then it got a little bit
weird cuz we were two stacking pieces of
some in on him you know like you know
what he was basically hit like a I mean
it look like he was in his own little
nine eleven there you know he's just
like in a big pile of rubble somebody
wasn't karate chop yeah yeah seemed like
did you ever have that teacher that
would come to school it was always like
this weird teacher he would come to
school and do like the karate
presentation for the student body you
get bruh have that oh you're bringing
him back some memory I mean you yes a
vague memory of like you know sort of
like a fifty year old man like a huge
you know in the white karate jersey or
whatever you call it via yeah yeah big
be thank you yeah that was a big thing
in the South where every like other year
something one teacher will put on like a
skilled ahead in this one dude head on
numchucks I guess you know and he had an
assistant and he literally they started
it and he hit this girl right in the
neck so and then they just shut it down
I was knowing with numchucks knows how
to use them yeah thank you thank you did
she okay
and that should be a crime oh who knows
I mean this was uh that's a different
time when they didn't care for every was
okay you know but um anyway so yeah not
trying to you know but I would see I saw
this the only experience I had with
being around somebody with Tourette's
when I was young and this isn't about me
but it was just uh you know this boy
that had it and how people would react
to him and then you know people would do
things like I remember a lot of people
would like kind of hug him or push on
him sometimes and it would it would make
him kind of feel okay or comfortable for
a little bit did you find ways that made
the Tourette's feel more comfortable to
you or to kind of like quell it so that
it didn't build up so fast cuz like you
said you relieved it with a tick yeah it
would release it or relieve it and then
it would start to build up again I tried
so many different things okay I mean I I
did medications okay well the the cool
thing is with that analogy that I was
describing with the itch and the scratch
now sort of looking back I see that and
again not a doctor this is my my
diagnosis of how I how I saw it
when you take medication in a sense that
numbs the edge okay
so now if the itch is numbed you have
less of a desire to want to scratch that
itch because you don't feel it as much
so for a lot of people with Tourette's
or sort of other neurological disorders
like that I think that's so beneficial
and helpful to them because they don't
have that desire like that you're not
taking as much okay for me though the
consequence and the ramifications were
the side effects from the medication oh
really like I got wild ones what is it
good what is some of the side oh someone
said it was I mean I had sedation I just
was sleeping all the time even one time
I had really suicidal thoughts yeah and
I wasn't a really depressed person right
but it it just messes with you yeah and
you're not you're not the same it's sort
of like there's this kind of wall or
this sort of like buffer between you and
the world yeah a little are you and your
cell phone most a little bit this many
more what it's like you know that was my
experience with it you know and that's a
very accurate experience I found that
with antidepressant it's it's like yeah
I don't feel depressed but I also don't
know if I'm a hundred percent and I'm
just sort of separated from my feelings
overall so I don't feel as much of
whatever my feelings are yes and for
somebody that might be worth the trade
right but for you that wasn't it was not
worth it no it wasn't worth it I mean I
was yeah I mean it's and it's just tough
I mean you're in such a difficult
position already you know I mean to be
for a lot of people in my situation or
your tics are that bad you're trying to
do whatever you can to end this you just
I just remember a lot of times crying
because it was just so really and it was
like wow and you know I was an
interesting person you got diagnosed
with it I was diagnosed I mean I had
it's not self diagnosed but this is not
yeah I didn't have a self diagnosis I
mean I started when I was real little so
I had you know like little things like
sniffing and oh yeah my brother even put
like a contraption on my nose when I was
a kid because that was like like imagine
it wasn't sniffing it was like an
outward sniff so imagine like your
little brother like constantly sniffing
on your face
so yeah yeah I could see it being
alarming after a while alarming for you
know just it's not even alarming like
maybe something's wrong it's like what's
happening you know yeah weird yeah my my
brother's a French Bulldog all of a
sudden you know or something you know so
I kept doing stuff like that and then
supposedly the the way it goes down is
my dad was reading and Ann Landers which
was uh I don't know if it's still round
but it's like a cot a medical column or
something in the newspaper yeah was she
medical was it medical and Lana's kinda
they they what they have Dear Abby was
self something like but some sort of
self help ya know she was like a grandma
that gave me good advice oh yeah
and so yeah he was reading the article
and so the way I kind of imagined it you
know he's reading the article and sees
me and reads the article and sees me and
eventually and he goes you know maybe
he's got Tourette's right it was an
article about Tourette's and the Ann
Landers and we went to a neurologist and
you know there's no blood tests or
anything like this this is uh
oh really so that nothing like that
there's nothing like that this is a
behavioral thing and yeah I think in
order to be diagnosed with Tourette's
you need to have both motor and vocal
tics I had both at the time both I had
both I mean you were making the the joke
about the friend that you knew I used to
take the N word as well oh yeah so I'm
with you're gonna do it do it you know
go all out and if I get busted saying it
to it I don't have Tourette's you know
or I might put that day you do yeah I'm
gonna put that out there right now but
yeah it's like if somebody you know so
you would say that you'd say you set
them all me it would get I did
everything did you have control like you
know if an n-word was coming you're like
oh [ __ ] I got to get to a white area of
town I I mean that's pretty much how it
was I mean well the thing is with the
analogy that I was describing to you so
first off I wasn't saying the n-word
when I was you know in fourth grade
right but you know I've heard of some
cases where you know you hear some kids
are saying just inappropriate things
when they're young yeah not even that
they have a they're not even cognitive
to understand what they're saying I
don't even think you know right it's
just maybe they know it's not a good
word right you know or something like
that but as I got older I also had
pretty serious OCD and the OCD was based
in obsessive
a compulsive disorder and it was
basically the same thing as the
Tourette's in the sense of there's this
uncomfortable feeling and I have to do
something do you rid of this okay so the
way that it manifested for me was I
would I used to think of what's the
riskiest thing I could do mmm-hmm
and whatever the hell that was that
became my itch so I used to say so give
me an example of that your mother so I
used to stick my hand down the garbage
disposal oh yeah yeah my bob was what
she heard that I was doing that that was
good yeah that's a it's not a sin it's
not that I don't like my fingers yeah I
mean I'm so grateful to have my fingers
but there was just this you want to ride
the darkness you know how to ride the
darkness yeah and sometimes I would lift
myself over in it the ledge of if I'm on
a on a building or you know I had a
friend's patio or something and then
when you're around people I used to
think of what's the riskiest thing I
could say and this isn't you know rocket
science right think about any time you
meet somebody oh yeah within a half a
second you know you could you know three
risky things you could say to that
person hmm that would either offend them
or would be about their insecurities
yeah
within a half a second you know
definitely dude you know so instantly I
would see someone so if I saw you know
really of that person what would you saw
me yeah what'd you say I maybe would say
it today well the thing is so growing up
you know the mullet was something that
was like totally not okay yeah for us
you know I'm a would maybe take like
Hoosier right or mullet I would maybe
start ticking mullet Oh just start
saying something so it's like something
that feels forbidden that you maybe
wouldn't say yes that thing starts to
bubble up in the back yeah it's crazy I
gotta say this if you wonder them what's
in my pants you know what it is actually
I had a dream last night that I was
wearing something beautiful and I woke
up in me undies me undies are the best
underwear I've worn probably in my life
I would say honestly probably 13
different brands underwear and none of
them have made me feel as cool calm
collected and just dang outright good
and that's me undies it's like a safety
deposit box for your crotch make you
feel so soft
the undies are made from micro modal
fabric which is three times softer than
regular cotton and it's been tested by
bunnies and people that that and that
little bear on downy on that downy
softener that you shouldn't drink either
that stuff is for your washer 100%
satisfaction guaranteed with me undies
that's right you're gonna love these
undies but if you're not into it you can
just send them on back hey you ever
ordered underwear through the through
the mail
well now you can send yours back very
similar but different and you can get a
full refund from the undies they just
launched as well they just launched a
brand new membership you can level up
your top drawer with new undies every
month and support this past weekend get
your 15% off your first pair that's free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to meet undies
comm slash weekend that's right me
undies dot-com slash weekend tag us in
one of your post if you put it on a
social media on your story so we can
share it
we love me on these my whole crew is in
them let us hold your junk for you me on
DS comm slash weekend don't laugh so
hold on no II know I'm curious about
this because you know what to so like
say if I you know look at you right and
I would think like you know I would
think this you know the first thing I
would think would be what's that store
that's in all the malls you know what
said uh you know that one I know the one
that kept is the one that goes that's in
every mall where people buy like nice
clothes but it's even in like smaller
moles to Banana Republic mm-hmm so I'll
we think like Banana Republic like right
when I saw you you know we're like J
Crew or something you know like kind of
like a put together kind of you know men
shop right okay and not and so but like
yeah I might not just say that right
when I saw you you know like I wouldn't
think of that as even as a bad thing but
it's like oh you know you see the guys
nice he's put together so I think oh
this that might be something popping on
my head man and Republic you know J Crew
um you know Wells Fargo something in my
head that pops up so then if I was just
sitting there now is that an idea
that comes to you here's what I'm asking
sorry is it an idea that comes to you of
something a negative to say yes okay so
it's an idea I'm literally thinking
what's the worst thing I could say right
now okay and whatever that was that
became the itch I don't know the physics
behind that like the mechanics of how
that worked it is actually them but it
was just until I then said that word so
if I was with you right oh my god I
gotta say mola I gotta say mo and I'm
this dialogue is going on in my head
right and it was all so hard about it
does it just mean an ass don't mean it
some people it's just be there just
being an [ __ ] if they have that
what's the difference between somebody
who's just an [ __ ] and somebody who
is Tourette's then I guess that's a good
question
the thing is is that I don't think I
think it's more about the person's
intent okay you know so where there's a
lot of you know there's people who say a
lot of mean things to people right and
they are purposely trying to hurt the
person correct meaning you know trying
to degrade trying to do something to
take him down yeah we're with me with
the Tourette's syndrome and I think you
know most people with Tourette's
syndrome that wasn't what I ultimately
was trying to do even though it seemed
from the outside dude you're just saying
you're just saying really offensive
things yeah and you mentioned that you
were gonna I don't know if we were gonna
watch it later or not but there's a clip
from South Park yeah I don't know if
that's one of the ones that you saw yeah
it is yeah we have some do you want to
pop it on down it sure is like a cough
or a sneeze that it isn't contagious
like some people think a lot of people
with Tourette's have different takes
magic
is that I have to bend my neck and snap
my fingers but a lot of people don't
even notice it really isn't all that fun
[ __ ] pass coming from my who is that
Nick Swardson I think the last one was
actually Nick Swardson
maybe Nick Swardson Esther I heard he
might he told me the other day he's
gonna [ __ ] out of his armpit so and I
think that and that was in a Christmas
card so he certainly may have it okay so
we see a clip like that right first up
I'm laughing cuz I haven't seen that in
a long time right all right I mean South
Park is brilliant I mean I think just in
general I think they have a certain
brilliance of how they do things
yes London I had I really had a belief
growing up that you have to make light
of things
mm-hmm and I also I had an amazing
support system with my family and I had
a belief that if I wanted to be if I
wanted people to be tolerant of me I
also needed to be tolerant to people
okay mmm and I mean when I see that now
it's a little bit different from when I
had it but it also was I mean it's
really funny
I'm yes oh yeah when he sees it when the
very first scene when Cartman finds it
he learns about Tourette syndrome for us
he goes I found the gold in Terry and he
seeks this whole song and it had to the
because he found a way to be able to say
what he wants to say whatever he wants
to say yes right and that's why I was
thinking of this clip because when
you're asking about you know what's the
difference between somebody who's just a
jerk right and it's you know I don't
think most people with Tourette's view
it that way
I don't think that they're the kind of
person or I know no I agree you know
it's like it's you know because and this
is the other thing to it so there's
funny parts to it and it's great and
then there's also all the other times
you don't it's not funny right you know
like I was you know I had an older
brother that that like men and was gay
right that's tough too you know
constantly be around your brother in
oh yeah tick really offensive things for
gay people right right so yes it is
funny mm-hmm and then there's also the
pain right of what it's like to be in
front of people I mean I had black
friends yeah I had great black friends
yeah
taking the n-word right in front of
their face but then also like you're
like a lesson for everybody in you know
since it's involuntary you have the
ability to be a way that everybody could
kind of just learn about you know
tolerance really you know it's almost
like you're just like kind of like this
tutorial kind of this bootleg tutorial
that's kind of floating around the
universe when you have it of you know be
tolerant you know because it's not it's
coming from another realm really it's
not you know it's not like you're
sitting there and you got a 30-second
timer and you clock in and then you know
in 29 seconds you're gonna straight up
dropping in bomb you know or uh you know
that's crazy that it's almost like
you're like the Bruce Willis of like
profanity kind of I feel like you know
yeah I mean it was you know every pop
quiz hot shot I mean this for me I
wasn't an e to everybody but it was more
than just cuss words - I'm taking racial
slurs cuss words you know if I you know
walked up to somebody and they had a
mole yeah I which are taking mole you
know and that was right with Austin
Powers thank you yes
Austin Powers came out with the whole
volleyball the glow yeah that was real
though for video moles were hella
popular then is it going back out of
style along with Fred Savage that was
Fred Savage they had that mole in Austin
Powers oh it's true one and if you have
a mole dude I had some moles I was
growing up and I like a normal person
caught them all off one night when I was
drunk in high school which is something
I highly recommend to a lot of people
dude what happens because I had the same
thought a couple times oh I just took
some toenail clippers and just saw them
all off dude had a couple of drinks one
of them kept coming back for about six
years and finally I got to the root of
it you got to get in there
there but you know what think it's
fascinating man when I hear you talk
about this and look we're just yeah
we're joking about this in some light
you know it's like but we're not I'm not
you know discrediting that that you know
the disease or people that suffer from
it you know at all like and I think it's
I think it's fascinating man I mean I
couldn't I'm trying to equate it to like
what does it feel like because I have
this feeling inside of me sometimes that
makes me want to like do something bad
you know it's like a misbehavior almost
it's like and for me sometimes it's like
a you know some people will call like an
alcoholism or something inside of them
that like it's like a restless irritable
discontent feeds almost like when you
see a power line and it's cut and it's
on the street but it's still alive you
know it's like that's that's the feeling
you get inside of myself sometimes at
night and it's like I can't it's like I
want to do something it's just like I
need to do something right now and I
don't even know what it is but it's like
I need to do something so I can just
then I'll be okay what I don't even know
I don't even know what it is but when
you're talking about Tourette's it made
me think like man that's I that's
something like that I get but it's in my
whole being it's like in my and I guess
when you really have Tourette's and you
have that I can't imagine I have some
control of whether or not I do something
I can't imagine not having control and
knowing that whatever this is like a
champagne bubble is just gonna bubble up
to the surface of you yeah I don't I
think it's actually pretty correct what
you're saying I mean I really believe
sort of everybody has Tourette's now
yeah and again I I won't keep qualifying
it but it's this is my experience now
you know of my journey living with
Tourette's for 20 years right you know
my friends and I we think when I wrote
my first book we were estimating mm-hmm
I probably ticked around 25 million
times you know that's like comes out to
like over 3,000 times like that you know
so you know really experiencing
Tourette's knowing what it was like
living with a day in day out and then
overcoming it and going through that
journey yeah I I just
and feel about it very differently now
and I sort of think that in a sense we
all have tourettes yeah and I so I think
it's it doesn't make sense that you say
that as I'm describing it you're like
and I wonder if I feel I think I know
that feeling or might know that feeling
I can relate a little bit feeling really
can it I don't mean that I'm not saying
that I can relate to having Tourette's
but I can when you said that minutes it
was very specific like man that's the
feeling that I get it's like a
uncontrollable thing and it it's in me
and I can feel it like it's almost like
an amoeba or something that is like
alive and it's like it's not really in a
specific spot but it's like on the edge
of my skin it's in my throat and it
makes me want to do something you know
it makes me want to you know for me it
usually comes out in like a master like
masturbation smoking cigarettes makes
you want to do something bad to myself
that's what I feel like for me but yeah
so I can I could I can't imagine if
you're just sitting there like an old
and you just feel the Dark Arts but uh
why don't what I what I don't know is
why that feeling started for me ah you
know and was there a time before that
you didn't have it I mean supposedly you
know I started ticking when I was around
four or five okay and so whatever it was
you know my my body whatever it was just
let's say it is genetic let's just say
it is you know I mean I experienced it
way less that way but who knows
but maybe my you know one of my mentors
said to me um you know maybe your body
had a genetic predisposition towards
feeling that feeling right okay so maybe
my body was more sensitive in feeling
that feeling and as I just grew up you
know as a little kid and you feel that
feeling what do you do as a little kid
if you feel uncomfortable yeah you do
whatever you can to not feel
uncomfortable right so literally this is
how I hypothesize and yeah
I'm sitting there one day I'm making
this up yes I have a feeling and I go I
don't like that okay I feel better right
done and the 22nd so I two minutes five
minutes ago by an office and the feeling
comes back again and I go oh I know how
to get rid of that feeling yeah yeah
and it just goes on and on and on so the
way that I think about my Tourette's is
that in a sense that I was a type of
positive feedback loop mm-hmm that I
just continued to do and I didn't ever
learn like a self soothing type of thing
yeah and I never learned a different way
to deal or cope with that feeling right
you know it wasn't you and who knows if
you would have this is probably your but
there's a lot of times naturally you'll
do what you need to do yeah you know and
some people I don't know the exact
statistic but you know 50 maybe 50
percent of people grow out of Tourette's
you know and some people's tics wax and
wane and different things and so you
know everyone's got a different body a
different they were late to their body
differently sensations in their body
yeah but you know all these different
kinds of things so and do you have to
now say if are there people who are
diagnosed with like do you does a doctor
diagnose you is it how does the
diagnosis go because when I saw it went
out when I was like watching somebody
chuckles I was like this guy doesn't
have any this guy seems fine you know
this guy seems good you know well it's
it just depends on what went when what
videos you saw right and when right now
yes when you go back to the ones from
you growing up and different points your
life and showing like it's like oh wow
that would be weird imagine that what do
we have the ability to play of the TIC
compilation yes absolutely ticks out no
it's your mark it would just have been
mark Elliot tick compilation okay let's
I want to see these bad boys because I'm
not sure which one you yet but which
videos you saw and can you put some uh
they'll be sound with had some trap trap
music in the background have you heard
of that you remix your tics dude how
have you not remixed your tics dude
we'll have somebody somebody fan of the
show we'll definitely put some trap
music
Tourette's dude how do they not have I
bet well they have it now oh so this one
once I beat it I used to then play this
clip really gonna give my speeches
because no one would believe me that I
had Tourette's that you had
geez geez [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I have Tourette's by the way just throw
that out there okay
[Music]
what's that guy work we're trying to buy
some from you know this was a security
guard about the library
[Music]
it was actually very gracious was so was
this is this something that so you have
this bite it's like a sound and abiding
for some people to only be able to hear
this it's me going like this huh huh huh
yeah basically like Peyton Manning
you're like Drew Brees basically but
whatever snap in the ball no it's really
I'm living my dream of being a QB right
all the time just non-stop but that was
so blue 42 through 42
it must be an arrowhead of something
because they can't see him Stacy on high
in it's a feeling that's for that you
know feeling in my teeth it's a feeling
in my throat
you know how does this really tell like
the Cerebral Palsy almost cuz use now it
cuz that I feel like are like a I'm
trying to think of something that would
be like the deep end of maybe along that
same spectrum you know where it like
it's just so much where you can't even I
don't know it enough the way that a
doctor explained to me pretty early on
they described Tourette syndrome as the
mother disorder to me okay because we're
talking in the realm of neurological
genetic sort of involuntary disorders
because you can't really compare treads
to like MS oh that's what I was thinkin
that's those things like that in the
same way because with my very little
knowledge right those kinds of things
like you know like a tremor is that's
something that's happening truly not at
the will of the person like if you have
Parkinson's I think it's you know their
arm is shaking it's not just like oh I
have this itch and I need to keep going
like this it's like their the physiology
is doing that okay we're with the
Tourette's it's not like my mouth was
it's not that my mouth just did that
from a divine right it's you I'm saying
mark okay you need to move your mouth
now okay I feel better to get better
yeah so that's why it's it's different
the way that I that a way that I
understand it but but it is the mother
disorder
okay so underneath it they would
disorder mother so it's kind of the root
of
some of those other disorders you're
saying when you said the mother disorder
what I don't know if it's the root but
he the way he described it is if there's
this umbrella and the top is Tourette's
there's a lot of comorbid disorders so
like a DD ADHD social anxiety anxiety
OCD those kinds of things and oftentimes
people that are diagnosed with
Tourette's those other disorders are
much more debilitating them than the
ticking itself right you know cuz if
you've got really bad OCD and that can
really mess with you and limit you and
what you can do in life oh yeah we had a
dude I remember in school and he had a
um I guess it was like a big bag or
something and every I mean two three
times a day he'd have to get in this bag
it was like a huge duffel bag you know
like a ski equipment bag and this dude
yes
yeah get in it zip it up and then get
back out you know it was like he was
like a magician like he worked like a
magician's assistant but there was no
magician you know you just see this to
just lay his bag down get in a bag zip
it up from the inside then unzip and get
back out and just sit back and it's to
ask you here he goes again and it was
just like damn you know
Lonnie's bagging himself you know and
everybody was just losing their minds
but but I think it's funny the different
dis you know like man I can you know is
the more you say some of this stuff man
and I'm not trying to make this about me
at all but it makes me think a lot about
how people describe alcoholism you know
how they describe it like it is this
thing that they just feel like they have
to do there's a something inside of them
that is an uncomfort that makes them
then feel like they have to engage in
drugs alcohol illicit activities to
quell the uncomfort it's not like most
of the time it's not people like oh I
love the taste of beer all the time
that's why I drink or that's our love
cocaine it's like there's a none comfort
and to quell it these are the things
that I'm using you know so it's really
fascinating because it sounds in some
ways like some of the roots are the same
there's an uncomfort that builds up and
then you are doing your you're doing
something just to relieve it just to
make it go away it's not and it's going
to come back yes and so how do you get
for
where you were then to where you are now
where now you know you don't you are you
know recovering you're recovering
Tourette's I'm a recovering sicker a
recovering what oh no I made the joke a
recovering ticker oh yeah hey recovering
take on I just want to say you know I I
do understand what you're saying and I
don't think it's that far of a stretch
right what you're describing yeah which
I know is a sensitive issue yeah yeah I
know it is - yeah and so you know
because we also just live in very
sensitive times right now yeah that's
true you know and so it's it's difficult
because some of the things that I'm
trying to say it's it's a delicate
balance because I'm one I'm sharing my
experience right I do believe though
that by sharing some of my experience it
might shed light into other people's
experience of them dealing with
Tourette's yeah because growing up I
only saw it one way hmm
it was you have Tourette's this
neurological genetic disorder that's in
volunteering has no cure so you know
with respect to that feeling it's kind
of the way I think about so if there's
that feeling and as I got older I had
more of that awareness about okay look
I've got this itch in the scratch I
don't know how else to change it though
this is this is this is my like the
Itchy and Scratchy show from Simpsons a
little bit but like in one person in one
person yeah can you imagine it's based
like Tom and Jerry constantly all the
time and they're both characters both
characters and it's also I'm it was a
war zone on the inside Wow because not
only was I just you know we one thing if
it was just myself on the planet and
there's not a single person it's just me
all day
scratching right you know but it was you
know I didn't have a lot of
self-confidence I'm so I'm thinking
about the feeling and then I'm going oh
my god I'm about to take mullet what's
the--oh gonna think about me oh my god
is he gonna be offended oh my god what's
going and all this is going on through
my head or imagine you know your body
awareness yeah yeah or when I was in an
airport I would take bomb all the time
you know things like that so it's you
know or me more funny ones to when I was
with a girl I would tick other girls
names I really take the pee war
no you say I would take any word
everything matters crazy
imagine if right when you pick a girl up
and you're like drop her off early you
just she can tell immediately the funny
thing is what time there's a girl now
there is a get it out of your system the
rest of us up to mill around my you know
just [ __ ] forty dollars at Chili's
and then we're not interested it's more
of a test so if you say you kind of just
see where they're at and then but what
the funniest thing was the one of those
uncomfortable things wasn't even a
sexual term it was I met a girl just I
just I was crazy about this could we go
on the first date and I start ticking I
love you oh the first date I mean that
is that was painful it away oh that's
painful I've done that over text you
where you get a girl's number and then
seven minutes later you're like I love
you I think you get blocked I think I
have text Reds but no man uh and I
should've made a joke out of that moment
that's a real moment man ah I can't
imagine that dude because then it's like
well did that start to show you
something like unique about like
feelings and stuff though because then
it's like you know save you because
there is something funny if you meet a
girl on like in your head you know you
go off and you know this adventure like
I'm in love with this girl there's
something special and and sometimes that
happens just immediately out of the gate
you know you and within two minutes you
have all of these you know you guys are
living in a castle and she's butanol
these perfect things going on in your
head did you start to find that
sometimes your Tourette's was a good
like crystal ball of people that were
like good people or people that meant
something to you I didn't feel it that
way you didn't it was just a nightmare
it was it was but you know what I'm
saying I know what you're saying but it
just was it wasn't that it wasn't that
wrong it really was I had no control
over my mind
yeah no control over my body yeah and
that is why though I think it relates to
so many things because that feeling
whatever it is for people we all have
these feelings and so often don't feel
we have control and what makes
Tourette's unique I think is that and
again I haven't been
holic I haven't done these things but
for all of us that have that feeling you
know if you have that uncomfortable
feeling and you want to get a drink you
have to go get a drink
or if you want to overeat or you want to
just eat to cover that feeling you got
to go to the refrigerator whatever it is
mm-hmm with Tourette syndrome you don't
have to go anywhere for it mmm it's just
right in your body it's like a one-stop
so this just a one-stop shop so I you
know in some sense I think that's what
makes it unique but I think would also
then makes it very universal is is that
we all and I think those you know as a
society we have trouble dealing with
those feelings
right and I just learned a very specific
way to do it
genetic or not it doesn't really matter
hmm that was just how went for me that
you learn a very specific way to deal
with that feeling and what I think makes
it also different is you know when
somebody like have you ever you know
been uncomfortable and you just go to
the refrigerator oh yeah I don't even
realize it maybe you just use all of a
sudden at the refrigerator the thing is
we don't call that a medical condition
right that's just you dealing a canned
yeah snacking you know and again it's
not like snacking is the same thing the
same no no way that's okay you can you
know for a kid that's taking a bunch of
freaks man audience it's like totally uh
you know usually understanding about
like you know discussing things but I
think it's neat is that for me when I
started to shift my perception that way
with help everything changed but I want
to know what is so that it seemed like
you had you started to find some
solution for yourself in that moment so
as I was describing with the metaphor
isn't metaphor and analogy I'm not sure
it's okay dude yeah I don't know
anything and everybody's been listening
for a while now yeah okay so that if
I've got that dynamic I got this itch
and I got the scratch basically when I
was a kid
doctors told me hey that itch by the way
that's a neurological genetic
involuntary thing you might just let it
go so imagine as a kid what do you think
I do when they tell me that that just
becomes basically the law of gravity
like I don't even question that ever
you don't even question what the the
desire to act out or do something or say
something stranger because it's
they told me that's well that's just
science that's gravity that you have 'ti
that's Tourette's right and remember
it's no cure
this is involuntary this is genetic yeah
I mean think of those words as a child
as you're hearing those words like it's
genetic it's involved you know
neurological you know especially if yeah
yeah yeah oh I would think it would very
smut sentence you to a way of thought
and believed yeah and it were a great
doctors by the way yeah these were good
people I even know some of them still
you know it but why then as a child with
respect to this whole itching and
scratching and ticking and all this
stuff why would I ever evaluate it again
or even know how to evaluate right it's
just okay this whole thing that's going
on this is Tourette's right it's all
just under one big label of Tourette's
syndrome okay so what took you out of
that and I know you're getting there so
just I wanted to preface that because
that helps see it's like why would you
ever question that right like if people
tell you like yeah you're you'll you'll
never bend your leg from a kid I mean
you're a child then you'll just probably
think your whole life you never will
exactly yeah and rarely would some
people even think to go back and think
well can I be mom yes and when I when I
speak often times you know I talk about
with childhood like we're told so many
things as a kid oh yeah that some are
totally true and some were totally false
though yeah so you know this is just
what you're told and the thing is is the
one caveat to that is as a kid you don't
know the difference between what's true
and false right so you don't know the
difference between Santa Claus and eat
your veggies yeah it's the same thing oh
it's interesting I was talking about
that last night that kids believe that
Santa Claus exists that's [ __ ]
baffling dude it's badly there's a
senior citizen in the sky no I'm saying
traveling like that they'd shoot him
down over half these countries Somali
this day and age oh you know many other
small slaves would pull up alongside
them in Somalia steal all of his [ __ ]
pirates yeah different times you know so
but yet but as a kid we believe that
wholeheartedly so really does make you
wonder the mind of a kid that it's good
to try that on right right so then when
I was older I guess this is now eight
year nine years ago I met this other
speaker and he introduced me to these
amazing classes called executive success
programs
and these courses had nothing to do with
Tourette's nothing at zero to do with
Tourette's and okay these are classes
that teach people about emotional
intelligence fears limiting beliefs all
those sorts of things things that you
don't learn in regular school right so
what he's due to name Gary that did it
Gary
yeah that did what told you about the
classes no his name was Daniel oh sorry
that's so funny your mind reader as well
no I just know dude named Gary and he
sent me some links but I was just
wondering the same guy Gary white he'll
oh I don't know Gary white oh yeah in
the serene guy the cool thing was I
ended up finally going to the classes
again zero to do with Tourette syndrome
okay they just teach you about the human
psychodynamic so I end up going through
the classes it's a 16 day course and
after the first five days I started to
learn so much about myself of just how I
work and again when I say and I learned
about myself right literally what I'm
saying is you go to school to learn
about math the arithmetic that's math
yeah is it also yeah you learn about
those days right yeah but outdoors those
kinds of things when you're an adult
right there's a bunch of things at
school most schools general public
doesn't teach you about like how do you
deal with fear how do you deal with
failure yeah like things that are very
real onerous and you're just kind of
supposed to figure it out when you're
older kind of thing
yeah like how's race relations not a
class that they have in elementary
school all of that stuff yes okay but
unbelievable and how do you kids about a
[ __ ] Gerald Ford dude you know I'm
saying who I think played for the
Celtics there was a president who gives
a [ __ ] what I'm saying I'm saying yeah
emotional intelligence should be the
number one thing we're TS kids are how
to communicate science who is he play
for the lines he did drove for her for -
pretty sure present the day yeah did he
see that actually is that not true did I
make that up see that ok I've no idea
go on but the point is I didn't learn
about those kinds of things and I
started going through it I started
learning about these things right and
I'm in the executive which is called
again it's called executive success
program ok so I started to learn a lot
about the nature of fear as well now
with OCD remember
I also had really bad OCD and I started
like starting putting pieces together
ago you know why it like maybe that
feeling that I've been talking about I
go maybe there's I have a bunch of fears
around it because there was you know
that remember it's like you have to do
something to feel better so if you don't
do it it's not okay right and I started
realizing like maybe I have maybe I have
some fears there so right after the
first five days I ended up going down to
Panama I had a a bunch of speaking gigs
in Panama and with my OCD and stuff with
the Tourette's I had a bunch of [ __ ]
around my face and touching you maybe
have heard of people like this oh yeah
you can't you know cuz germs and all
that did that oh yeah and I read tagging
themselves all the day yeah yeah [ __ ]
some dude just sitting there pattycake
in himself and he [ __ ] if you almost
knocked himself out one time it's about
800 feet
you know it's like you make your joke
but seriously sometimes if a friend
touch my like one side my face I'll go
dude you got touch mother said yeah just
stuff like that who did so funny say
this when I used to walk down the chute
and I was young I wouldn't I would like
bite mama this side of my mouth and then
I want to provide on this side of my
mouth same and I would bite on the side
him off and that dude ah I did that for
probably eight years man okay and then
when it went away I never [ __ ] I
would it was all I would think about
when I was walking and biting make his
trial was even and then when it finally
went away I never [ __ ] thought about
it ever again until pretty much maybe
now and one other time in the past 25
years so similar stuff to that so
basically I'm at the beach and I go you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna start
going against this and I had you know
get all these fears about Germans and my
face and I go eff this and I take all
the sand on the beach and I start
rubbing it all over my face and it was I
really look at that as at the beginning
of beating my Tourette's because it was
it was finally me going you don't
control me mm I'm gonna start taking
control here and and that experience was
just so emotional and also just I open
for me because I you know what do you
think I said to myself after that like
I'm rubbing this all
now that I'm there and I go I'm okay uh
yeah I'm okay
right like yeah the devil didn't come a
dragon didn't the the earth didn't split
open and fire yes you know all the kids
from my childhood and he can come back
and rip me back into the [ __ ]
universe and none of my genitals off no
no so I ended up going through more of
the classes and the president the
company her name was Nancy Salzmann and
she ended up coming to my training and
on the sixth day you start to look at
fears and it was really cool because I
had had enough shifts at this point that
I go you know what I might be afraid of
losing Tourette's mm-hmm you might be
afraid of losing it losing it like
stopping it like it and again I know it
sounds crazy and it was if you would
have liked I would have known you Theo
back then and you would have known me
the day before I would have started that
training yeah and if you would have said
hey Marc you might be afraid of losing
Tourette's I would have been like what
did you just say to me why cuz it was
your identity it was so much and again I
wouldn't even if even if you would have
said markets part of your identity go
what do you mean it's part of my
identity yeah I wouldn't even even have
known how to talk to you about that oh
yeah this is just I have Tourette's that
wow boy yeah you know so wow that is
crazy that somebody would say that
because it's the last thing you would
think but you found that there was truth
in it for me there was truth and I
started to do a bunch of explorations
and I finished that course and that was
really all about the Tourette's was like
you know looking at the fear but I just
started learning just a lot more about
my mind and my thoughts and how a lot
about the mind-body connection and about
how you know things are connected and so
that was September that she's me that
was over a summer I took that whole
course the whole school year went by and
back on the road speaking at the time I
was a I was speaking a lot of high
schools and colleges all around the
country and didn't know more the classes
by the end of that school year that
feeling had gone down so much that
literally I started to need to almost
like fabricate ticking a little bit mmm
oh wow so now
be playing in a role of a ticker yes I
still needed to tee I still had the urge
to tick so it wasn't like it was done by
rights but it was you know these people
are hiring me and I had Tourette's
syndrome you better show up with [ __ ]
Tourette's yes I'm saying if you say
you're a [ __ ] you know running dope
you better show up what a mule you like
that kind of thing tell me it's milk
exactly so at that point I go you know
what mark you can beat this and I end up
going back the following summer and I
took some more courses really I was
there for 17 days and now I came with
the intention and every day I worked on
my mind my by everything relating to the
trust anything that I could think of
that because basically what I found was
is that my Tourette's was way more
emotional and psychological than it was
physiological well man it's a I can't
even tell you enough like everything
you're saying it's very similar to stuff
that you hear in a lot of like 12-step
programs you know it's like it's
whatever's behind the behavior yes
well ultimately and what I when I talk
to people about is that I found not I
found through the help of some amazing
people and tools I found the cause of
your Tourette's of the tread and let me
let me clarify let me clarify I don't
even know if I found the the cause cause
of it all but I found a way to short
short circuit the whole system yeah and
I found of so much of what was causing
that feeling so that's I'm saying I
don't know what originally caused it
mm-hmm like how that feeling got there
right fine maybe it's neurological
genetic who cares right okay great
so I had it question is what can you do
now yeah and you know with the
incredible help of these people and an
ESP I I found a way to begin to undo it
so those were course you willing to now
what about somebody who doesn't have the
money to go to courses or who's not like
what can you know somebody that has like
a tick even even if their tick isn't at
the level where they would get them you
know it'd be classified as Tourette's no
I believe that there is a bigger thing
going on in the world where it's like we
don't use our
human interaction isn't as used as much
anymore like we're kind of out of this
like colonial survival kind of times and
tribal times when we're getting a lot
more than like a sedate time and so our
nerves which used to be like kind of the
leaders of like what was going on what
was over the the ledge if somebody was
outside is my family all in the home you
know that system that was always running
and it's a security system now has kind
of been like Idol in us for a long time
and so it seems like I wouldn't be
surprised if there could be things
starting to kink in it or you know it's
settling into it's kind of new
unnecessary system you know unnecessary
use mm-hmm so I could see like a lot of
things like alcoholism Tourette's like
just malfunctions of it you know or
errors in the city you know just from
not use you know like because when you
think about how much in a couple of
generations we're not using our
fight-or-flight much at all and to think
such a powerful system sitting inside of
us it's like what's going on there you
know it's almost pretty bizarre and I
have no proof of that but when I just
think of things on like a more of like a
macro level I could easily see in
hearing you say that and seeing how many
people are like you know struggling with
their feelings and stuff these days and
and and feeling like a desire but not
knowing what to do I could see a lot of
that being a little bit in the same
umbrella like you were talking about
earlier you know yeah I think it's but
but back to the question what do people
do if they don't have that they don't
have the ability to go to the executive
programming and they don't have that
well I think I mean one I hope even just
being able to talk about it like this
can begin to help somebody see what if
there's a different way you can look at
it right you know because
okay so reframe something for me well
simply even as I've been describing is
when I grew up for 20 years this is
neurological genetic involuntary
disorder with no cure so the question is
okay maybe that's true maybe that's not
the what an individual can start
thinking about is what if that's not
true what if that's not true like why I
think just in general
what would it mean to be just more
curious about yourself and your life
let's say you can't go get help you
can't do whatever what you know can you
just start questioning yourself and go
right what if it could be different
again I mean the way that it started was
you know I did I went to a class had a
really different insights into myself
and then I went to a beach and I go I'm
gonna do something different here yeah
I'm gonna start thinking about this and
see what's on the other side contrary
action you know because it was just so
emotional for me not to do that oh yeah
so I think really one of the biggest
prerequisites for anything in life if
you want to change is you have to one be
curious yeah and you have to want to
change oh yeah yeah they had a dude I
remember his dude Samuel when I was
growing up they said he couldn't walk
right he's in a wheelchair
mm-hmm it turned out his parents were
too lazy they never taught him to walk
so turns out one day he [ __ ] got off
you know couple buddies helped him in
the gym and by the afternoon he's
shooting hoops you know this was someone
you knew and it's like what the [ __ ] man
you know like but if he doesn't ever get
curious or question that thing if you
just sit in his chair forever think I'm
like yeah this is where I'm gonna be and
then when you say that well you were
talked about as contrary acts you're
talking about like man I don't want
germs I don't want things in my face
when things touch my skin it makes me
feel uncomfortable
I'm gonna [ __ ] stick my head into the
[ __ ] universe you know two handfuls
at a time yes and go through the
looking-glass I mean that's next level
that's next level in that moment for you
but it's also it's just contrary action
it's like yeah like I have trouble like
um you know there's a lot of therapists
methods where it's like okay let's look
through your past and think of what
happened and try and figure it out and
then there's a lot more active proactive
therapist methods that I've found from
going to therapy were like I don't care
what happened in your past if you want
to have a better sexual relationship
with your girlfriend you need to get in
bed with your girlfriend and lay there
and start there as opposed to sitting in
a room and wondering well I don't know
why we have these problems you know like
but I've definitely started to notice
that there's two methods from going to
therapists and so it's kind of like what
you're describing it's like you can sit
there and
the facts and go through and the file
folders and look back through a lot of
your history or you can like you did you
had a frame of reference a frame of
perspective it sounds like an just I
want to say for me what was cool is I it
was really both ways because by going
through the class and and really really
what happened is is that I was able to
proactively yeah lower that feeling so
that itch within about a year and a half
went down 90% Wow
so and and a lot of that feeling I found
was through bunch of triggers throughout
my whole life so it was this beautiful
synergy between going deep in there and
the other reason I felt lucky is because
a lot of people are willing to go deep
in there but they don't have a tool that
really can help them find where to go
meet how to get rid of it it ends up
that the tool was incredibly sharp and
so I was able to go in there and as I
was going through some of these
processes which is just conversations
with people I would have this amazing
experience or realization and all of a
sudden that feeling would go boom boom
I'm doing down because the feeling would
start going down so it wasn't like I for
a way that a lot of people a way that I
think a lot of people try to beat their
Tourette's or help their treads or
whether it's alcoholism OCD or anything
in life where it's a type of challenge
like that sometimes you just sort of
stick your head down and you just lean
right into it and you go yeah and that's
that's great and that is what some of
what I did but what's also really nice
iswhat if there's a way that you can
make that that really uncomfortable
feeling diminish yeah and so you don't
it's not such a a mountain to climb
right and that's why I feel so grateful
because I didn't have to go climb a
mountain right I had to work my ass off
yeah and there was something deep inside
of me yeah some I also was really sick
as a baby for an intestinal thing and I
think that that played a lot into it but
I I have
a really strong will right and I was
willing to on that beach go you're going
in yeah and I don't know where that came
from
yeah but I had that in combination with
a group of people in tools that made
that battle so much easier he need help
does that make sense yeah so it wasn't
just like I was like a Spartan going
yeah it was I was a Spartan plus I had I
don't even know what every training
wheel humans yes heart neurs you had
people that knew what to do yes you had
conversations that a lot of time can
unlock yes yeah that literally unlock
out my potential my my I mean literally
the way that I connect with it is they
helped me in combination with how hard I
worked I literally became more conscious
I became more self-aware and that I go
oh that that feeling and one metaphor
that I'd tell people as a way to
describe this is one way that I got
helped is so there's this feeling and I
was a little kid and I go oh that's a
bad feeling that's a shitty bad feeling
but what if there was a way when I was a
little kid which was not possible hmm
that I could have decided it was a good
feeling
mmm and the way that I think about it is
do you do you like massages mm-hmm do
you like the kind of massages where it's
like super painful like elbow in the
back oh dude I told him last week we
paid a couple Vietnamese dues to beat us
up down 70 so you like you're one of
those sickos you like open air and
everything you'll come off the ropes
he'll do whatever yes one so you like it
hard right yeah I like some attack in
there okay a little bit of [ __ ] you
know Vietnam to do you know what I'm
saying yes I don't know how that ends
but it's about a half hour the question
is though do you know people though that
don't like it hard like that yes okay so
this is what's so interesting here you
have two people getting a massage and
one person loves the pain another person
hates the pain so what if when I was a
kid I could have changed my perception
of that feeling
like I had that uncomfortable feeling
hmm what if I could have loved it right
right yeah what if you'd even been
somebody that loved it
yeah now again there's no way I could
have done that right as a jet but some
people get scared and they get excited
that baffles me sometimes some people
like you know like Evel Knievel's they
jump off the stuff in there I ride up
dude if I go flying off of someone a
motorcycle yes not doing well yes you
know and I wouldn't even try I mean
behind me that's like a nightmare yeah I
would think of it as a nightmare
but it's interesting how some feelings
to some people are totally a feeling so
what I was able to do with the help of
all these people is that I was literally
able to manufacture and literally almost
rebuild my pathways you EMDR did you do
that or no mm-hmm
it was all through this whole are a lot
of it was through minute I know it's a
lot of work that stuff is a lot you know
it's a lot of work if you want to go
back and really work on stuff you know I
know that it is a lot of work yes the
cool thing was is that my experience was
is that the way that the process was it
was incredibly it was formatted it was
formatted and it was also very simple
and at the end not as simple you have to
be very skilled to work with somebody
but meaning within 30 minutes you know I
could talk about an experience and feel
very different do you work with this
company now is this a yes you're
partnered with so it was really cool is
that so I was going around the country
speaking you know four years and then
you know it was an interesting thing
like I'm on the stage you know in 2011 I
was college speaker in the United States
by a Campus Activities magazine okay so
I'm just a NACA into those at all those
things yeah apke all those oh yeah so
there is I'm sharing that it's cuz like
my whole life was Tourette's you know
and I'm going around talking about
Tourette's and oh yeah yeah really bad
boy bro you know and I was my whole
thing was really about kindness it was
really about tolerance and kindness and
it was an interesting thing though
because now here I'm trying to help
people on stage and yet I'm getting
helped in a whole other way like I'm
getting penicillin back here right and
I'm having a forty minute talk with
people
so when I realized that there was a way
that I could help people in this way
that's how I wanted to learn how to help
people
I see so you were helping people you
were talking about Tourette's and then
you got involved with the ESP group yes
okay mmm and so you know I was able to
do that over the last you know five
years and it's been unbelievable and one
cool thing was after we started after
you know what happened to me and again
he had nothing to do with Tourette's but
once it happened you know the founders
they started going you know Keith
Ranieri and Nancy Salzmann I think they
started go what if we could what if we
could replicate this with other people
and so over the last four years we've
been able to replicate with ten other
people with us get into the program and
get better yes Wow
what we created a special thing just for
people with Tourette's
and this is the crazy thing so it took
me like a year and a half to get down
ninety percent as I was describing guess
how fast it's been replicated I don't
know that one guess seven seven what I
don't know like seven months yeah I
think so four hours oh wow
Jesus man I hate guessing people can get
rid of using this rats and for no they
can't that really so I kid you not it
was probably worthless like something I
would say I'm dead serious
so this so I want to be really clear
it's not saying hey anybody can get rid
of their Tourette syndrome saying people
that had severe Tourette syndrome that
had tried tons of different things that
wanted that deeply wanted to get rid of
it and end it for themself and also you
know we went through quite an interview
process because we're looking we were
looking for very specific people that
you know we thought just met a bunch of
different conditions that not know that
they would be a good candidate for this
for all of those people I would say
seven seven or eight to a three out of
the ten are down 70% Wow
and the other six seven are down 90-plus
Wow and what we so need is is that once
this started happening over the last of
four years we have this incredible
filmmaker who he goes we got to start
filming this so we started to film it
and so what was so neat is is that you
know I would find someone with
Tourette's or someone would tell me
about somebody with Tourette's yeah and
we would go through this whole process
to see if they would be a good candidate
and then once we thought if we had you
know a good candidate a film crew would
go out to their life film their whole
life with Tourette's they would come
work with us in Albany beat their
Tourette's and then we would go back
into their life and film their life
without Tourette syndrome do you guys
y'all are not like in the it's not you
guys can't be like in the Special
Olympics or anything I feel like you can
[ __ ] run that [ __ ] if you could Titan
I can't be in the Special Olympics no
but I will tell you I'd much rather just
train for the regular Olympics now I
mean just because it's I mean life is so
different now is it really what do you
miss about having Tourette's man like
really having it you know the thing that
I I miss is I miss in some ways
everything about for one sec I I trying
to think I'm not try and think what I
would the thing is you people knew me
yeah oh you're a rare element I remember
knew you people knew you so part of what
my experience has been over the years is
that I had to start how to learn in a
way that I never did before
how to relate with people hmm I can
understand that and I think you know
that's not unique to Tourette's I think
we all have different thing you know
Yura I don't I don't know a lot of your
history but I you know you were a
comedian oh you've been a comedian in a
long time
yeah so now imagine if somebody said hey
Theo comedies done never can make a joke
again and then think about what it would
mean to how every conversation now you
had with somebody that's bad it's a
really good of correlation man I'd be
baffling you know and so that's also
what was so neat is is that I was going
through the classes I was taking a lot I
was doing a lot of work to also build a
foundation
and just to learn how to be more me how
to learn how to be with people again
because my whole life I always have the
Tourette's I always had this this thing
yeah and that so it was it was
interesting because you know the first
the whole journey was beating the
Tourette's right and then there was a
whole other journey after that were you
without the Tourette exactly he was
almost like yours like he it was he now
you're Clark Kent you're like well who
the [ __ ] is who who am i yes it's funny
to say some of that when I was um you
know in high school or right out of high
school I guy I did reality television I
worked on MTV for a little while and I
remember after that you got real popular
and went to school and all these kids
knew you and this is back I only had you
know 40 television channels and but then
after that I didn't know I still
would've been like reformative years I
didn't really know who I was you know I
was just kind of getting out into
college end of the world and then I
became you know I was this guy that was
on this on television you know and and
it was very uncomfortable to get away
from that I mean I remember having
visceral reactions I remember I'd go to
the gym and like I would sweat and
without even doing anything my head it
would each I'd feel these needles in my
neck and head and like extreme uncomfort
because I had I was nobody without that
thing kind of yes and I didn't want to
be that I didn't like that you know and
I didn't and I wanted to get away from
that but at the same time I was like I
had no clue out who I was you know
because for a couple years this was kind
of who I what it just gave me everybody
always came and talked about that or
that was the thing or something or you
know and it was just hard to be it was
hard to learn who I was you know yes I
can't even fathom that man like being in
this shaky cage and all of a sudden you
know you're out of the cage and you're
like well [ __ ] it's kind of wild out
here it's been wild and I think about
naked almost you know and I absolutely
and I absolutely fell naked and I think
what's hard for a lot of people that
were close to me was growing up I was I
was such this gregarious kid and I was
outgoing I was you know I was student
body president of my high school I did
plays and sports I became an
inspirational speaker but how could you
do all that what
- Rhett someone well the thing is I
learn to compensate so much right that I
did and again I had this incredible
support system that I mean that what
most people don't have but I I learned
too that even because I didn't have that
that strong sense of self yeah I just
did whatever I could to try to be normal
to try to get people to like me because
I felt it I was because I was three I
felt like always three steps behind as I
had the tourettes yeah so the moment I
started I met you I'm already behind us
I got the tret so I kind of make up for
all this stuff so that you go okay but
you like me in my okay just yeah so that
really has been the most profound
experience of all this is finally
starting just to be more me yeah and
just going I mean now I when I talk to
friends to like the way that I think
about my life is like my whole life I
was in the deep end of the water yeah I
didn't know how to tread well and I'm
just you know trying to figure it out
get by not offend people what are people
thinking you know all that stuff and and
really only like the last two years did
it feel like I made it to the shallow
end and I just started walking out of
the room yeah and then I'm that and that
it's just like I'm learning how to be
normal yeah but just like on the inside
it's just so much more quiet now and I
can just learn how to be with somebody
and be with me yeah and something that I
never imagined I'd even know that could
exist for me like it was just right it
yeah it was like a it was like being
another ethnicity almost or being in a
certain yes yeah so that's been I it
really has been these different journeys
but so I'm excited to keep keep going
keep finding more of me now and a really
it can it flare back up Tourette's so
the thing is I don't I don't think of it
in that way or experience it in that way
because I mean the way that I also look
at it now is you know I I have like a
very serious impulse disorder okay but
you so but it is still Tourette's though
well what I'm saying is
like that feeling that we're gonna call
Toretto okay like it was uh like I had
an extreme impulse disorder okay
like any feeling that I felt I I indulge
right okay okay now again by no means
that maybe that's an involuntary feeling
that I had right and I had no way to do
it differently right so over the years
I've gone through a lot of what with a
lot of work on myself in training to
really learn how to become less
impulsive as well right and so what are
the what are some of those things that
people can use even if they're not doing
Tourette's the thing is it's what can
people do it's I wish you would take the
court like because the course is where
you guys take it where and where I don't
know unfortunately the courses don't
even exist at the moment right now but
if they had the courses like yeah
someone can't couldn't afford to go to a
school or go to a place or get into a
program like that meditation it sounds
like is one good thing yeah I think
doing one things like that is meditation
of course when I have Tourette's and
someone said do meditation I said you
know go screw yourself right it's like
thing you commented oh yeah right but
they generally help Tom get help but it
was so hard for me because as I was just
typing I had no it wasn't quiet on the
inside and it's easy to say to someone
or just try to go higher it's like a
Best Buy in their Black Friday inside of
you it was crazy
yeah so you know I think I think the
best advice for somebody is try to begin
to challenge things if you want that
right and I wish that I could say what
what do they do in the four hours and
four hours with respect to somebody yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's cuz you just tell
them what you just said for four hours
no you don't tell that for four hours so
the thing is I mean the methodology it's
it's a profound way to help somebody
basically break limiting beliefs and
help them become more rational hmm so
you know it's so like it's try if you're
trying to help somebody with like let's
say you're still you know an adult and
you walk around still believing in Santa
Claus we can work with somebody to start
to ask them a bunch of questions where
they on their own begin to realize Santa
Clauses
true I say okay that's a really cool
process take somebody with that you need
to be very skilled to do yeah you got to
be skilled you have to be skilled to
help lead somebody to help them deduce
things on their own yes
that's a B Cobleskill so what and what
made it so powerful and why it could
happen in four hours is because somebody
wasn't deductively telling me it mmm if
somebody could so for instance if I mean
it would be insane if somebody goes up
to somebody with Tourette's cuz they've
heard this interview and go uh don't
tick yeah that would be Nollywood it'd
be insane it would be um a couple
pointers for you bucko yeah I I don't
even think that would be moral it would
be it would I don't think that would be
a good thing the old school for sure
part of the reason that I was able to
buy it so permanent is because I was
able to as you said deduce on my own
those realizations and when you have
that type of realization it's it's like
a perceptual shift it's permanent yes so
does that mean that I have no feelings
in my body anymore absolutely not do I
still feel that tourette itch very
little yeah and I still do things to
help change my relationship with it but
to say that I have Tourette's syndrome
at this point I think would be insulting
to somebody that really is struggling
right deeply with it so within those
four hours you know it's it's it's
trying to help somebody
it's not about reframing or you know
feel the feeling but don't do it it's
really helping them have really neat
insight into how they relate with that
feeling and also figure out what's going
on in their life that might be causing
that feeling yeah and that's how we were
able to how I not I how Nancy was able
you know to help people yes so quickly
and the cool thing is is that this past
year a documentary came out and you can
literally see on the screen you can see
this happen you can see within four
hours you know it's it's it's a it's
profound yeah to watch and I really
believe that you know one day that this
you know sort of this methodology and
also this movie can really open the eyes
for a lot of people because I believe
that this can open the doors for
Tourette's for a DD ADHD social anxiety
anxiety OCD ya know I think some of the
stuff you're saying it's like even if
someone had Tourette's right who knows
what other stuff builds around that over
time and magnifies it so much more
yes whereas even if you can go back
through and scrape away some of those
things by helping them deduce in their
own time in their own react so it
actually they figure it out which is
such an articulate thing that some
therapists are able to do because they
ask you questions and they help you
figure out in a way where you figure it
out yes they don't you're not telling
somebody something then Nikki you can
knock away so much of the stuff that
that makes everything so much tougher
you know whether it be Tourette's or I
mean it's just some of the stuff they're
using in a lot of other programs in some
ways but I think that's fascinating man
you know and it's just the power of like
people helping people you know I always
wish I had a stuttered I had a dude boss
named Douglas you've all right and he
was he might even had a start he might
have been pretty ignorant honestly but
he was a nice kid but I remember he had
a stutter in school and I thought it was
the coolest thing ever and I didn't
personate him and he'd be like what are
you doing you're making fun of him and
I'm like nah just I want it I want to be
like this you know this guy's so unique
but yeah I guess I don't know man it's
definitely fascinating and it's
definitely seems like it's been quite a
journey you know I can feel that you're
passionate about it you know it's been
an incredible journey yeah I mean I've
learned you know just so much about just
the human human behavior human the way
that we interact with each other the way
that we treat people yeah and that's
really why you know when I started
speaking 10 years ago it was all about
kindness because basically people people
were making judgments and assumptions
about me without knowing me which is
normal right it's normal you see
somebody you you think it's okay to
think negative things about people yeah
the question is is do you really know
what's going on right and so I think it
was a neat thing because here it was I
was doing all these crazy things and
people were acting on those judgments or
acting on those assumptions and then
they they took whatever they saw me
doing as if it was truth hmm
and so really when I started speaking
the message
about the first phrase that I used was
live and let live yeah I want to live my
life you live your life but really it's
like look if you don't like can you
recognize that whatever you're thinking
about that person you don't really know
right and if you don't really know no
matter how much hate you have towards
that person can we at least be kind
right can we can we at least treat
people with kindness even if we have
really negative feelings about them
because we don't really ultimately know
yeah you don't know if the guy's being
rude to you you know or I was having a
tough morning or just cut you off you
don't know if he you know his house just
burned down or you know he just lost
somebody or if even just killed us yeah
you know you don't know if he just
killed somebody like you don't know what
he's going through you know like you
don't know what somebody's going through
sometimes but ya know look I think it's
fascinating to hear about it's
fascinating to hear like you know like
your respect for the Tourette's
condition you know like the level that
you feel like you you know you had it
how you envisioned it how you you know
recognize it inside of yourself and you
know ways that you use to deteriorate it
you know or quell it to a place that's
more manageable for you and and and that
you're able to be aware of that at the
same time so that you can you know
communicate it to other people I mean
yeah I mean it's definitely you know cuz
I was like this I was like this mark it
doesn't seem like he has Tourette's you
know but then when you get in and you
hear about it it's like oh well this is
very relatable I feel like you know but
there's a couple of videos we want to
play real quick of a couple of nature's
leaders into that yeah and we actually
had one caller callin with a question
too about living with it but yeah we can
focus on it and then after that we'll
look at some examples of Tourette's and
pop culture and we'll get your grade on
how it was depicted sure okay it's a
great photo there it was pretty good
actually
how's it quite as dense as a stencil you
know I don't know who did that some man
sent that in probably honestly some do
actually really are you're gonna [ __ ]
probably so there's a lot of sweet some
real lurkers my beautiful live on I'm a
huge fan have a question for your
gastrous who had threats of syndrome how
often did you get late by you had
Tourette's syndrome and how hard was it
to get women or men if you're into that
respect and then how often have you
gotten laid since you stopped your
Tourette's intro alright god bless you
goodnight that god bless you came in a
little surprising but I still respect it
own word oh man it was so uncomfortable
with women really oh man well partly
because how little self-confidence I had
yeah again it's all you know it's always
easy okay looking at someone from the
outside you think you know what's going
on yeah but on the inside I you know I I
did not feel that confident about myself
though it looked like I was super
confident because of the level of
compensation that I was doing all the
time yeah were you doing crazy stuff
were you wearing necklaces and stuff
like that like were you trying no it was
like I was trying to look like I was
super rich but I was trying to look like
I was put together right and I wasn't a
[ __ ] show on the inside right were you
wearing like a um tuxedo and stuff like
that
not no luckily no I still had some
semblance of like let's try to be oh
good yeah you can't be showing up I
guess to them you know like your job you
know Joe black course exactly and if he
had at a rave or something but it was
weird with women I mean it was I mean
just imagine hooking up with a girl and
yeah you just crushed it out is it
easier now my game oh it is infinitely
easier but it's also just because I am
more confidence with myself yeah
so after I you know I beat the Tourette
syndrome I mean just to sex it one thing
you just imagine sitting with a girl in
not saying the riskiest thing oh yeah I
can't but I could definitely say this
dude beat Tourette's let's [ __ ] would be
the best book ever that is what we're
talking about but I do want to let
people know that uh that that um you
have a book you have two books now what
do you have tell me I have a book that
came out about six years ago called what
makes you tick okay
and but another book would be I think
really good at this point you know
because I that book I had just started
ESP and and and beating like the 90%
when that book came out and I also just
wasn't as open about my participation in
ESP at the moment just because you know
there was about there was bad stuff
about ESP back then there's even more
bad stuff about ESP now and it's like
landmark is that like a group kind of no
it's unfortunately it's I mean it's
definitely the same realm you know it's
in terms of it's a group of people that
are trying to help people yeah you know
but now it's in the news with a bunch of
controversy around and things like that
and that's not the set is it we did we
have uh we have Michael Rosenbaum on
here yes unfortunately yes same group
Wow so it's you know it's it's been a
profound journey to a friend sent to me
recently so here I used to have
Tourette's and I used to experience so
much prejudice because I was taking the
n-word in public and now that I've
beaten Tourette and now I'm just a white
guy walking around it's in a way I'm
experiencing more prejudice now Wow and
so yeah welcome to the club dude you
know at least you got to say it a bunch
yeah I hope that made sense is that the
the reason I said about and now I'm a
white male is because white males in our
culture don't experience a lot of
prejudice Oh relative to a lot of you
know compared a white male compared to
someone with Tourette's experiences less
I see what you're saying
so it's interesting now of still seeing
is that even without the treads I'm
still learning so many lessons about
prejudice yeah and the nature of how we
treat people and how we label people
whether it's a group or or a syndrome or
whatever it might be yeah so yeah we
battled with that too is I get you know
in comedy and just talking about stuff
it's like it's different you know
I mean I don't even think you could
legally hey you couldn't even have
Tourette's today in Los Angeles like
they feel like they'd hang you at the at
the cross if you dropped a couple of
bombs out there you know like when I was
growing up you could have some
Tourette's you know you'd have a dude
you know everybody you know people could
have something's you know they carry to
do it over there in the area and he sets
off a couple of em bombs or use them but
inappropriate turn if you were more
understanding can you even have
Tourette's nowadays and be accepted well
the thing is I mean that
but were I was really open and I you
know my family really was supportive and
we pushed it I would always tell people
I had Tourette's I would make
announcements on youngins in my classes
I think in general most people are I
think at the core do you want to be
understanding
I think what's difficult is that we live
in a time where where people don't
there's not a lot of critical thinking
and and people who are so quick to yeah
just be me just be mean or jump on the
bandwagon of being on with other people
and whatever it is they don't want to
communicate so it's weird that they
would say somewhat Tourette's has a
problem communicating and now it's like
so I'd rather have Tourette's and be you
know one of these social justice
warriors who's just beaten everybody who
doesn't have a conversation sometimes
you know well I think I mean one of the
big things that I in trying to talk
about kindness and stuff is it's
interesting how we as a society we fight
bullying yeah the bullying right we
fight hate with hate yeah and the
questions do we want to do we want to
continue to perpetuate that or do we
recognize maybe there's other ways that
we can treat people I love that man I
agree with that a bunch you know it's
like even yeah it fascinates me
sometimes how much people will be
hateful and just because it matches
their point of view that it's okay to be
hateful you know it's like oh you can't
be hateful but as long as but I can't
you know it's like yeah how do you not
recognize I mean being hateful is being
hateful you know but it's going well I
want to say it's not that I'm above that
right I used to so much all the time
fight hate with hate yeah you know even
when you know it's growing up with my
older brother who was gay man I was one
of those people at Pioneer and you know
if you didn't like gay marriage oh I
hated you right and then luckily you
know through a lot of my education and
going through some of the classes too
I've started to really want to be
different yeah and recognize you know
what I do there are things that I really
dislike or people that I don't dislike
and the question is okay can i still be
different even if I feel that way yeah
yes that's it that's the biggest thing
it's like yeah I know some great people
who don't like who probably would be who
who would be against gay marriage right
and I'm
gonna hate those people for that they're
great they're good people
just because their belief system or
whoever taught them or something naked
that's their thing like it doesn't mean
that they would be rude to gay people or
that they would treat them differently
they may have some old you know a
religious belief and that's their thing
it's like or anybody's religion that
doesn't mean I have to believe it it
doesn't mean I have to agree with it but
also it's gonna have to shun somebody
because you know their beliefs are
different than mine you know it's it's
baffling to me that we do that and why
would we do it you know because it's not
understanding its it's not accepting
really well the reason I think we do it
is because I think we're not aware of
how we all do do that yeah and that was
also mmm that's a good point and it's
also you know it was like part of my
journey with the Tourette's syndrome it
was I couldn't even see that though even
just about the fear of losing trans I
wasn't even willing to look at that
maybe not even willing I didn't even
know and so it was with help that I
could start to become more aware of that
and then when you start realizing like
you know what I also don't like a lot of
people or I know what I also feel
negative feelings towards people that's
when you can start to have a little bit
more compassion when you see someone
else doing it you know but now we live
in a time where you know someone's
caught on video saying some prejudiced
thing and and then what do we do to that
person yeah we're completely prejudiced
to that person yeah instead of offering
that well how can we what can we learn
from this how come with this person you
know how can we accept them into a fold
and make them feel comfortable and make
them feel like oh we all make mistakes
you know and that doesn't mean you can't
hold them accountable still yeah a great
a hundred percent but the question is
can you hold someone accountable and
still be kind still you know and do you
think it's the media that's more like
that or Humanity is more like that I
struggle with that a lot I think the
media is just an extension of humanity I
think it's you know what's like you know
when someone talks about a company like
someone's like well this corporation
yeah and it's like look it's yes it's a
company but just people yeah
there's people it's fierce I've got a
robot you know it's it it's people and
so um I think this is hard for all of us
but uh I think it's it's just really
what I've come to learn so
throughout all this journey of you know
with the trust without rets my
experience now in the company
experiencing a lot of prejudice of I
don't really know a lot mhm
I do want to stand up for things but I
think there's different ways we can do
it I think you know when you look at
history and you look at someone like
Martin Luther King his whole message of
non-violence I'm here look what he stood
up for yeah what he did it non-violently
yeah with compassion that narrative is
basically non-existent right now
yeah and instead it's sort of you know
we live in a time where if you think
somebody did something wrong you point
the finger and and people will quote
Martin Luther King jr. and then go out
and beat somebody's ass too
it's like this is insane you know but
yeah I look man I love some of the ways
I love hearing some of this and being
reminded of it like you know I find
every day like I'm me I'll be mean about
stuff and then I'll realize that I had a
part in something off to go back and you
know apologize or you know I mean it's
and I'm with you too I mean this is a
constant journey for myself it's not
like I'm above this I don't do this it's
but it's more of I want to keep becoming
a person that's not like that yeah I
want to become a camera I want to I'm a
person who's you know what I can feel
really negative thoughts about somebody
and still be kind yeah that's not easy
say what you mean don't say it mean my
brother always says that to his kid
sometimes say what you mean
don't say it mean that's what he says I
mean it's just one little thing about
what you're saying but yeah I agree man
it's like I'll get upset at groups of
people sometimes and and then I'll be
like well what's really going on here
you know and but I think we're getting
to a place like that aside where people
are thinking about those types of things
more let's look at a couple more videos
real quick so we can shut it down over
here we got to cool this is from 1970s
Quincy okay
to haloperidol isn't it I'll be okay one
second after concentrating I'm gonna go
say when they want you got a courtroom
here and the kids got there the rest I
guess I feel like I swallowed a
butterfly collection oh you're gonna be
fine
I just want to scare them I feel so
small
I'm just think of David and Goliath I
don't have a slingshot doctor Quincy I
don't know if I can really go through
with this oh you're gonna be fine you
couldn't do it Tony are you going that's
Quincy is the movie and it's about it
was a TV show about some doctor psych no
just to help people I've never actually
seen that clip before oh well there you
go Nick did some good digging right
there I wouldn't want to disease at
night in the gaol really show up in the
morning with some wild clips yes so for
the people who are just listening that
guy he just had like facial tics and
stuff how did that look that looked
pretty
I mean I think you have a lot of people
who do those kinds of tics that don't
have Tourette syndrome I'm sure you've
met people that you know blink their
eyes and stuff and also if someone's
listening and you've been blinking your
eyes do you don't have to freak out it's
not like you have Tourette's that's you
might have dust you might need a air
purifier so that grade for that one that
was pretty low I'm not sure what was he
was also doing something that his hands
not not in an intensity like his
depiction how yeah they do a good job
what he doing a one to ten of that
taraji thought that was a pretty good I
mean especially with the eyes I mean
that's not what do you think of seven
I'll give it a six okay wow that was
lauded like at the time when I was doing
digging of like a just a good depiction
and and very educational I thought it
was my first standard so I could give it
a [ __ ] Lannister ethic got barely did
it that's why you know you gotta I want
to shake I want to see it real shake up
here we go this is a Amy Amy Poehler in
deuce Bigalow male gigolo okay
okay I'm sorry I have Tourette's
syndrome and it causes me to have these
uncontrollable outbursts it's not so bad
yeah it's okay I mean I can't leave
Rob's shinai and Rob Schneider seems
like the guy who tried to bang out
chicks with Tourette through different
syndromes and stuff easy bags of darks I
would give that one a lower one cuz
that's like I would give that more like
a three or four okay why is that thing
is is you know I was aware that I was
saying the bad word I would try to
muffle it okay you know so I used that
like ad words even you know times so if
I was gonna say the N word sometimes I
would add the word dad oh yeah yeah and
then it would yeah you know to try to
muffle it where that one seemed or you
start singing a rap song
yeah like shinka Potamus or something
like that well a lot of times I would I
would go huh hi hi even if it wasn't a
bad word like if I felt the ticker hi hi
oh right on like you're doing magic yeah
like you're starting like you're
introducing people to something hi there
yeah Wow bro now that's pretty cool
because then you're in like a wild it's
almost like you're in a game with
yourself sometimes yeah it was just a
nightmare of a game it was it was it's
like you're a move central nervous
system you know yeah let's look at one
more and get a rating on this one man so
what do you give a polar got a two on
that it was a bit over three or four
three three a small window between Amy
pillar and that guy from Quincy here's
our last one from TV 7th heaven
oh my until God said
[Music]
they're in church well I appreciate the
help his mother says he has a didi my
son doesn't have Tourette's syndrome
please don't run away
you're a B D I could deal with but this
you know
mmm-hmm dad's not accepting I actually
give that one a nine I mean that's
pretty I think it's a good depiction of
the Tourette's of what that's like and I
think it's also a good depiction of the
parents I think it's really hard yeah I
don't
it's though the it wasn't just like I
had Tourette's the whole family had
Tourette's uh you know I would tell
people when I would walk into a room or
a restaurant and I'd take the n-word and
I'm with some friends yeah no one knows
who said it right oh that's a fun it's
not fun it's crazy dude I'm saying
everyone turns and just looks everyone's
just as much of a culprit that I am yeah
oh that's true huh you're like Jesus
everybody looking at your mom like she
says it all the time did you pretend it
was your mom so you I didn't it was my
mom but it was something one of those
things were you that kind of
understanding didn't come until ad you
have to dress like a wig or kind of kid
just to pull it off though but I I mean
sometimes I would leave when I would go
to movie theaters I put washcloth in my
mouth
I had just one time when I was younger I
had a very serious situation with taking
the n-word but not gonna would I was
very lucky and also you know I did
whatever I because I wasn't I didn't
have negative intent yeah she'd do
something a lot of times if I did say
the n-word and there was a black person
that that heard me I would actually just
continue on with my days Rimel because
usually I was I imagined if you're gonna
say that to somebody and you're trying
to hurt them or you know really get
their attention you wouldn't just
pretend like it didn't just happen
Aurore i right right yeah you need it
yeah you need to live accordingly with
it what's actually occurring in your
life is that it's something that
happened you're just going on living
your life as if not you're standing
there looking at them then it's like
you're waiting to figure it out
and it's gonna be an interesting yeah
conversation a lot of uh yeah man I mean
I I just can't even imagine that what
was like do you ever get a bonus word
that you never got again that kind of
popped in I mean I've said everything
you can imagine it was one of your
favorites it would [ __ ] flare up
every now and then dude anything around
the holidays or something ah so hard to
say Theo I mean I had any time I see
someone the funny thing is they go mark
you remember that time when you you know
this happened you take them like do you
understand how many times that I took
how many of those moments I've had with
so many people one funny one when I was
in a fraternity somebody punched it was
we hit you know there was like a drunken
night at the house and somebody had
punched a wall oh excuse me a punched a
hole in the wall and the whole pledge
class had to come in front of it and I
started taking I did it oh yeah even
though I didn't do it oh you know things
like that you know I sort of just like
everyone starts laughing and you know
trial for murder
yeah you just say I'm guilty I'm guilty
Wow Mark Elliott man thank you so much
man for coming in and spending time with
us today man that's been fascinating
it's been a fun conversation and I hope
your holidays were great thank you so
much man and I hope you great holiday -
yeah mmm and I'll see in the future
appreciate it
cheers brother thanks Nick thanks Nick
and Michael Rosenbaum was in and that
was about the group was called Nexus or
something's that are different or I
think it was it's the parent company of
a bunch of different companies but
really what's been the most fascinating
part about it Robbie or some I've seen
one of them around town before something
or L no because it was rings that was
more of a restaurant in my interests but
it was you know it's so interesting
because you know Keith veneering Nancy
Salzmann who are the ones that created
you know ESP which are really
responsible for why you know I don't
have created the tools that help me be
Tourette syndrome it's just so
fascinating of how different they're
being portrayed in the media right now
because they're the group that those are
the same people that got in trouble with
the sex cult or whatever and all that
stuff yes really you know so it's it's
so interesting for me because the same
same people so it's so interesting for
me because it's just like as I was
describing with the Tourette syndrome is
that here people saw something they just
saw one moment in time mmm and then they
make that one moment in time as if
that's a truth and then they act on
those truths mmm
and so you know people that I you know
that are dear friends that are doing
really good things in the world things
that I'm doing in the world that are
really good it's so interesting to see
then how people can treat you just when
they hear that there's a label well and
this is why you're now really with my
speaking it's cool because ten years ago
I started talking about kindness and it
it couldn't be more apropos now but it's
not even just about Tourette syndrome
it's really looking at the title that I
have now is called guilty until proven
innocent hmm and really looking at not
only just the nature of how we place
verdicts on our own life yeah like with
the Tourette's mm-hmm as really was my
own mind placing a verdict but also the
way that we placed verdicts on other
people's life wow I could see that being
a like a good turn at like you know as a
second half of a speech or if you're
given a you know teaching people you
know yeah it's perfect you know did you
hey so you had experiences with those
people I mean you they taught you ESP
they took you through that program of
course I mean it Keith and Nancy and and
the these are dear friends of mine and
then the because we had Mike and Michael
in here and they did you ever see them
as being like cult like now the thing is
I mean it's just such a funny thing even
you know growing up you know you're
about Colts and all those sorts of
things
every wizardry and then it's just kind
of interesting is that once you're on
the other side and you see actually how
you know when you start using words like
Colt or something like that but
basically it stops people from from
critically thinking anymore that's true
and you know versus okay look you know
maybe someone's doing something that you
don't like or you don't know but the
question is is like well you know what
why is that bad you know if they're just
doing something that's different than
you right so would you say more they
were a helpful group of people that just
had to maybe wild sexual activity
sometimes I don't even I don't know
anything about that stuff do you even
know anything about that I don't even
know about that stuff I just know is
that these are people that have done
profound things in the world now and you
know stuff like with the Tourette's
project obviously it's a little bit on
hold at the moment right but I'm so
excited to bring that out into the world
I mean I think that we can help millions
and millions of people it's so
fascinating it it's just because yeah
like you're they get you get labeled a
you know involved in a behavior because
there's a lot of people out here doing
wild sex you know I'm saying I get
invites to do all kinds of things you
know they got some fellow most paid me
ten grand to go and you know thug out
his wife up there at a hostel somewhere
outside of San Francisco but I'm just
saying it's like there's Pete and that
guy might be a stand-up guy at a you
know at a Ford dealership or something
you just never know who you know who's
doing what and does it matter well
that's the thing because not only do I
not know about that stuff is that I
think the deeper and the bigger question
for our society is more is what I know
isn't good is not about a hypothetical
but trial by media
oh yes or things like this where is that
really how we want to be where you know
you have you know and I mentioned sort
of like you know if you point at
somebody now it's it's have you ever
seen the movie The Crucible mm-hm
if you haven't seen the movie see the
crucible uh Harriet Beecher Stowe who's
it was it was a long time ago but you
think it's Harriet it's again it's I'm
not saying if if you if you think
something is wrong it's important to
speak up about that
but how you do that's really important
yeah and you know with respect to the
media and how we treat people whether
it's through allegations whether it's
through gossip whether it's through any
of these things can we still be kind
yeah the media does not when the media
does not set a good example because it's
you know and maybe we don't if it's just
an extension of us maybe we don't
but yeah it's interesting you know they
don't put in those articles this is a
group that's helped millions of people
or hundreds of thousands of people well
in its it's and it's just saying you
know these are people being wild and you
know you know who knows what else yeah I
think it's really important that we as
adults we have to just be a lot more
mindful with respect to those types of
communications did you ever get invited
anything wild was there everything that
you never so you never thought anything
about and pretty cool though huh yeah
definitely for the Tourette's dude well
you but I think it's right up and
crossing guard brothers directing
traffic dude oh [ __ ] I never wasn't and
more than that I you really I just can't
continue to learn so much and so it's
been so beautiful of having Tourette's
experiencing prejudice not having
experiencing Tourette's and experience
experiencing prejudice and I really want
to become more of a voice in our country
and for the narrative of can we be kind
yeah even if you think you know things
are bad that are happening is there a
chance that what they were doing like it
they were doing something like roping
young women into this sex thing and it
is completely damnable and you just
aren't aware of it you only saw the good
like is there is there ever objective
times when people are wrong and you have
to be like no you can't do that the
thing is I don't even want to comment on
something that's like crazy
hypotheticals like that because Eddie
then it even validates that it's it's to
be speaking about that in the way is
legitimate what I do know is is that
even in or even if you know somebody did
something really bad what's so cool is
is that we have gold standards in our
society of how to treat people still mmm
maybe we can end on this you can go in
on YouTube and on YouTube you can find a
bunch of videos where someone has
murdered somebody's like someone has
murdered someone's son yeah and you see
the mob
of that a child completely treat that
murderer with love yeah and look that's
someone who's still being held
accountable but the mother doesn't need
to go destroy that person's life right
so I think that's really the bigger
thing you know in life you know people
make mistakes there's failures things
happen bad things happen sometimes but
even with that can we still treat people
with decency yeah so it's not really
about whether it's something did or
didn't it's it's what I do know is
what's happening right now in our
culture isn't good yeah yeah and I think
a lot of it does come back to how we
treat each other and it's funny when you
treat somebody with decency then they it
really in the end leaves them having to
think more about what they actually did
because they can't use that energy to
then be angry back at you it's not about
you and them it's about you know then
it's just them having it that you know
being set with the thoughts of what they
did you know I don't know it's
fascinating man
I mean we're you know we're late
bloomers in here so definitely learning
as we go but thank you so much for being
here mark Elliott thanks so much yep
[Music]